[Musik]
Finanzminister Christian Lindner gibt
grünes Licht für das 9-euro-ticket für
den Nachfolger Berlin weist polnische
reparationsförderung zurück und schwere
Vorwürfe gegen
ndr-politikschefen Julia Stein werden
erhoben dieser Recherchen des
sternzufolge 2020 im Berichterstattung
ihrer Kollegen eingegriffen haben es
geht um Kumpanei mit der Landespolitik
Parteilichkeit und politische
Einflussnahme und damit herzlich
willkommen bei viertel nach acht meine
Gäste heute Abend sind Publizist und
Auto Henrik Bruder ich freue mich immer
sehr wenn er hier ist wie Sie wissen
aber er ist wohl so furchteinflößend das
CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz zuletzt eine
Veranstaltung wegen ihm nicht besuchen
wollte Professorin Susanne Schröder sie
ist Ethnologin und Direktorin des
Frankfurter forscherzentrums globaler
Islam ihr Thema heute abend vogue und
kenzel culture der Westen ist am Ende
Katrin Seibert sie weiß was es bedeutet
vom öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk in
der Meinungsfreiheit eingeschränkt zu
werden sie war fast 20 Jahre für den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk tätig
und unter anderem dazu gezwungen ein
Interview mit einem Gesprächspartner zu
wiederholen der die Aktion alles auf den
Tisch als kriminell bezeichnet ich bin
sehr gespannt auf heute Abend und dabei
ist auch noch Hajo Seppelt ARD Doping
Experte und Autor sein Thema
Dopingmissbrauch und Schutzgeld
Erpressung die Schattenseiten des
Spitzensports und mein Name ist Nena
schick ich freue mich sehr ihre
Gastgeberin sein zu dürfen die
Schlagzeile die mich heute am meisten
beschäftigt hat kommt aus dem
Handelsblatt da stand nämlich der
Bundesrechnungshof fordert die Ampel zum
Sparen auf da habe ich erstmal gedacht
was steckt denn dahinter der
Bundesrechnungshof ist ja die externe
Finanzkontrolle des Bundes und der geht
jetzt einem neuen Bericht hart mit der
Bundesregierung ins Gericht der Vorwurf
die wahre Lage unserer Bundesfinanzen
werde aus dem Haushaltsentwurf nicht
deutlich der Bund habe zahlreiche
Ausgaben für wichtige Politikbereiche im
Sondervermögen ausgelagert die
eigentlich aber aus dem normalen Etap
finanziert werden könnten schreibt der
bundesrechnungsschreibt der Rechnungshof
ja ich würde das jetzt mal etwas
einfacher zusammenfassen eigentlich
wirft der Bundesgerichtshof
Augenwischerei vor und die echte
netto-kreditaufnahme sei vierfach höher
als die auf dem Papier vermerkte also
Finanzminister Christian Lindner und
seinem Ministerium wird platt gesagt
Verschleierung im Bundeshaushalt
vorgeworfen und da möchte ich jetzt
natürlich direkt von Herrn Bruder wissen
sind die Vorwürfe jetzt zu hart oder was
ist denn da los nein die Vorwürfe sind
überfällig die hatten auch schon vor
einer so zwei Jahren kommen können es
wird in der Tat ausgelagert mein
schönstes Beispiel dafür mit dem ich nie
gerechnet habe ist das sogenannte
Sondervermögen zu Sanierung der
Bundeswehr abgesehen davon dass da nicht
zu sanieren gibt heißt Sondervermögen in
dem Fall man nimmt Kredite auf soweit
ich weiß ich kann mich täuschen ist es
der erste Fall in der Geschichte der
Wirtschaft der Volkswirtschaft das
Schulden zu vermögen umformuliert werden
allerdings zu einem Sondervermögen und
das wird sonder zeigt schon eine gewisse
Barbara im Umgang mit der Sprache an
Sondervermögen tausend Milliarden kein
Mensch denkt mehr daran Sondervermögen
hört dass das Geld ist das vom Bund
aufgenommen wird und eigentlich 100
Milliarden von 100 Millionen würde kein
Mensch mehr reden
ja aber das ist es und der
Bundesrechnungshof geht eigentlich noch
sehr milder um er spricht auch vom
Mangel der Transparenz aber das ist das
Geschäftsprinzip man lagert bestimmte
Haushaltsposten aus damit der Haushalt
kleiner erscheint als er ist aber
eigentlich sollte sowas wie das
Sondervermögen zum Haushalt natürlich
gerechnet werden und deswegen der
Vorwurf der Verschleierung
betrug sprechen sie würden von Betrug
sprechen Frau Seibert wie haben sie das
aufgefasst dass die amplate sparen soll
und der Bundesrechnungshof da jetzt auch
wirklich sagt also so geht das hier
nicht mit dem Haushalt also da ich keine
Finanzexpertin bin kann ich einfach nur
dazu sagen es geht einfach wie immer ums
Vertrauen und da haben wir einfach jetzt
ein großes Problem also die Politik muss
etwas verkünden sie muss etwas was sie
muss Veränderungen vornehmen und das
Vertrauen in verschiedene Richtungen ist
einfach auch schon in weiten Teilen
verspielt wie man sieht und da ist jetzt
einfach gute Rat teuer
ja vielleicht hat der Bruder einen Rat
wie die Regierung es machen sollte nein
wenn ich Rat hätte die schon längst
darüber im Buch geschrieben aber in dem
Fall wird sich jeder blamieren der so
tut als hätte ein Rad schauen Sie das
Problem ist wir also ich nicht aber wir
haben wirklich Jahre wenn ich Jahrzehnte
mit Geld nur so herumgeschmissen wir
haben den Indern als Volk schätze ich
die sehr wir haben den inneren eine
Milliarde Euro überwiesen für die
Elektrifizierung der Straßenverkehrs
wenn wir jetzt ein Moment leise sind und
genau hinhören können sie hören wie die
Inder immer noch darüber lachen eine
Milliarde für die Elektrifizierung der
ringschatz wir haben den Taliban der
wirklich Namen hungerschutz stehen
dieser wohlgenährten Herren mit ihren
ganz neuen Kalaschnikows den haben wir
600 Millionen Euro überwiesen also Geld
war hier im Überfluss vorhanden und nie
eine Frage und irgendwann Recht sich das
eben sie können auch nicht jahrelang
Geld drucken wobei Geld wieder gar nicht
mehr gedruckt das schreibt sich die
Europäische Zentralbank einfach selber
gut zu denken
Jahre Jahre wahrscheinlich schon
Jahrzehnte permanent Geld in
Milliardenhöhe drucken und verteilen
ohne dass man die Konsequenzen ins Auge
fasst und die erleben wir jetzt ich
meine irgendwann holt einen die
Wirklichkeit immer ein meistens zu spät
Frösche wie schätzen Sie die Lage ein
wie steht Deutschland da
Deutschland steht im Moment so da dass
wir eine Regierung haben die aus drei
außerordentlich unterschiedlichen
Parteien zusammengesetzt ist und jeder
muss ihre Klientel bedienen und
der FDP fällt eigentlich zu das Geld der
Bürger beisammen zu halten und das
nehmen ihr würden ihr nun die anderen
beiden übel nehmen und deshalb wird er
so ein großer Budenzauber gemacht mit
Sondervermögen mit Geldern die
eigentlich
irgendwoher kommen keiner weiß genau
woher das hat alles gar nichts mit der
Schuldenbremse zu tun sondern das ist
irgendwie extra gelagert und wir haben
hofft dass es keiner mehr Christian
Lindner erwähnt die Schuldenbremse ja
oft erst da geht ja kaum also nicht
erwähnt aber sie sagen die wird nicht
konsequent überhaupt nicht umgesetzt
wenn man Sondervermögen einsetzt das
sind ja letztendlich nichts anderes als
Schulden die nur anders wie Herr Bruder
ja gesagt hat anders deklariert sie
würden also den Vorwurf der
Verschleierung unterstützen in dem Fall
absolut ja Herr Seppel wie sehen sie die
Lage in Deutschland den Haushalt machen
sie sich als Bürger sorgen ich mache mir
Sorgen um die Gesamtsituation der Welt
und nicht nur die Situation in
Deutschland das finde ich problematisch
und kleben zwischen diesem Land fast 60
Jahre und wir haben eine Situation wie
wir sie so noch nicht hatten und das
macht mir großen Kummer und aber ich
sehe auf der anderen Seite ich habe
Menschen und Freundinnen Ukraine ich
weiß wie es den Menschen dort geht und
ich weiß auch Menschen die hierher
gekommen sind denn es überhaupt nicht
gut geht und den wie ich finde wir alle
helfen müssen und deswegen sage ich
unterm Strich immer noch wir Jammern auf
sehr sehr hohem Niveau in diesem Land
und wir werden jetzt eine Situation
zusammen im Winter wahrscheinlich haben
die sicherlich manchen Leuten nicht
gefällt wir müssen Einsparungen
vornehmen wir werden Einschnitte erleben
aber ich weiß halt auch dass wir
eigentlich zufrieden sein könnte es in
diesem Land leben können wenn sie sagen
wir jammern auf hohem Niveau führen Sie
also Ihr Steuergeld noch gut angelegt im
Haushalt und in der Politik ja ich finde
es richtig ich finde es völlig in
Ordnung dass ich so viel Steuern zahle
wie ich zahle ich finde das völlig in
Ordnung sie können freiwillig mehr
zahlen wenn sie wollen gute Idee aber
vielleicht sollte ich das tun aber ich
versuche auf das ist eine gute Idee
also ich glaube
ja nach der Sendung habe ich was anderes
vor nein wer jammern nicht auf hohem
Niveau das ist schon sehr ein bisschen
zynisch es gibt Leute die jeden Euro
umdrehen müssen
wirklich ein großen Unterschied ausmacht
ob die Rolle beukeller Kekse 99 Cent
kostet
1,59 € sind und die haben nicht
erforschen aber das meinte ich auch
nicht so ich sage nur dass das ist uns
grundsätzlich in diesem Land meistens
besser geht als vielen Menschen auf der
Welt das ist was ich meine und ich bin
ja vergleichen ja tu nicht wissen Sie
ich bin ja nun durch meine
Berichterstattung in der Welt
rumgekommen und ich habe halt viel
gesehen und weil ich das gesehen habe
relativiert sich für mich manches
trotzdem haben sie völlig recht es gibt
Menschen die denen es nicht gut in
diesem Land geht aber ich weiß halt auch
beispielsweise wenn ich in anderen
Ländern unterwegs bin die haben noch
nicht mal Hartz IV die haben noch nicht
mehr Sozialhilfe da gibt's überhaupt
nichts ja und das ist noch viel
schlimmer das macht es nicht besser hier
das möchte ja nun ist das immer
schlimmer da haben sie wohl recht ja
aber das nicht besser und letztendlich
geht es ja auch nicht nur um das
Wohlbefinden von einigen Leuten sondern
es geht auch um die Wirtschaft und wenn
hier tatsächlich ganze
Wirtschaftsbereiche zusammenbrechen dann
hat das ganz andere Folgen als wenn
jemand aus der gehobenen Mittelklasse
vielleicht meinem Pulli anziehen muss
frau Seibert sie sind ja auch
alleinerziehend und haben ja auch Kinder
wie sehen Sie denn die aktuelle Lage in
diesem Land also jammern wir einfach auf
zu hohem Niveau und eigentlich haben wir
alle genug
also ich glaube noch geht es aber es
zeichnet sich ja jetzt ab sie haben
vorhin die Geschichte erzählt mit dem
Benzinkanistern dass die Leute also wenn
mal der Benzinpreis sich entsprechend
verändert dann gleich losrennen und sich
das Benzin abzapfen so welche Szenen hat
man ja in Deutschland
bisher zumindest noch nach meiner
Kenntnis nicht gesehen und ich glaube
schon dass es jetzt darum geht wirklich
genau hinzuschauen was passiert jetzt
wirklich also ich mache mir auch Sorgen
nicht um mich selbst sondern einfach um
um große Teile der Bevölkerung ich
glaube das ist uns sehr hart treffen
wird aber es gehört jetzt auch ein
bisschen dazu unsere Rolle als Medien
hier kritisch zu hinterfragen ich finde
immer Selbstreflexion wichtig und jetzt
schon wieder von dieser Angst zu
sprechen den Leuten Angst einzujagen das
ist eben ein sehr zweischneidiges
Schwert und man muss ja nach vorne
schauen man muss natürlich die Zukunft
planen aber gleichzeitig geht bei vielen
in der Bevölkerung auch so ein Reflex
hoch dass man sagt nein ich möchte nicht
noch mal mit dieser Angst konfrontiert
werden von Seiten der Medien über die
Politik die Politik verkündet die Medien
transportieren und dann sitzen wir
wieder da und müssen Angst haben also
da habe ich ja auch da bin ich ja auch
gegen aufgestanden gegen diese massive
Angst mache es gibt auch Experten die
sagen sogar wir machen noch zu wenig
Angst weil sie befürchten dass es große
Demonstrationen in Deutschland geben
wird aufgrund der steigenden Preise und
dann auch noch der zurückliegenden
corona-jahre
ja ich glaube man müsste halt einfach
wie praktischer an die Bevölkerung
herantreten warum setzt man jetzt nicht
einfach ein großes Ziel krisenexperten
ein und lässt ja aber wirklich die die
Kurse geben was macht man bei einem
Blackout zum Beispiel ich habe gerade
kürzlich einen kennengelernt durch einen
Zufall in dem Hotel der hat gesagt er
macht professionelles Blackout
Management und der entrichtet die Leute
was wie sie sich vorbereiten können was
passiert wenn wir wirklich Blackout
haben sie haben sie haben 20 Minuten
Zeit bis das Handy nicht zusammenbricht
wusste ich nicht fand ich hoch spannend
20 Minuten so weit dass wir Steuerzahler
uns auf Blackouts vorbereiten sollen mir
macht das Angst nicht Kampagne der
Medien haben ich glaube es ist gut wenn
man das mal gehört hat und wenn man sich
mal erkundigt hat okay was was ist wenn
wir wirklich kein Gas mehr haben wie
heize ich denn also ich stelle mich
jetzt darauf ein vielleicht muss ich
irgendwie mit meinen Kindern in die
schrebergartenhütte und da habe ich
jetzt irgendwie so und so viel Festmeter
Holz da ist aber der Preis ja auch schon
gestiegen oder ich muss in die Berge in
das kleine berghäus also irgendwas muss
ich mir ausstellen
berghäuschen und habe ich auch nicht
selbst sondern ich würde es mir dann bei
denen die den es gehört ausleihen nur so
ich bin skandalös dass ein Staat der uns
immer mehr vorschreibt was wir zu tun
haben wir zu reden haben welche Pronomen
wir benutzen sollen was wir zu essen
haben etc so eine wichtige Sache der
Daseinsvorsorge vollkommen privatisiert
das soll sich bitte der einzelne darum
kümmern das passiert wenn wir kein Gas
mehr da ist wenn das Handynetz
zusammenbricht wenn vielleicht der
nächste Supermarkt geplündert wird ich
muss sagen das ist ein starkes Stück
hinzu kommt noch etwas zwischendurch
einwerfen darf es hat hier in den
letzten Jahren eine Verblödung
stattgefunden wie es ihnen ein
aufgeklärten Gesellschaft noch nicht
gegeben hat ich sag mir nur ein Beispiel
aber es gibt mehr davon bei Baumärkten
sind die Heizlüfter ausverkauft die
Leute kaufen sich elektrische Heizlüfter
aus Angst vor einem Blackout weil bei
denen kommt der Strom da aus der
Steckdose wenn sie Leute so weit haben
dass sie sich dämmersten irrationalen
verblödet Verhalten könnten alles machen
es kapiert auch niemand dass der Staat
eigentlich kein Geld hat die Stadt ist
nur verteilungsmaschine aber alle sind
begeistert ich günstig den Leuten weil
sein 9 € Ticket hatten wird nur
vergessen dass das den Start zweieinhalb
bis drei Milliarden Euro gekostet hat
und das Geld kommt irgendwoher nämlich
aus den Taschen derjenigen die mit
Begeisterung für 9 € von Berchtesgaden
nach Kiel fahren also ich glaube es
lohnt sich schon auch ein bisschen
zurück zu gucken auf diesen Sommer also
Leute die sich nie irgendwie über die
Klimaanlage Gedanken machen mussten ist
wir hatten einfach ein unglaublich
heißen Sommer und ich mache mir da schon
Gedanken einfach um die Natur ich nenne
es jetzt mal Natur ne das Klima ist
jetzt schon wieder so ein Begriff mit
dem man schon wieder ganz viel
transportiert was man vielleicht gar
nicht will mir macht es Angst wenn ich
sehe dass die Wälder im Taunus
vertrocknen ja das größte
zusammenhängende Waldgebiet nach der
Lausitz wenn ich richtig informiert bin
vielleicht noch den Bayerischen Wald das
ist alles braun sind braun wenn ich aber
jetzt Richtung Bayern fahre wirds schon
wieder grün also ich mache mir Gedanken
um die Natur und um meine Umwelt und
schön ja und das ist für mich ein
genauso großes Thema wie das was jetzt
den Winter betrifft auch wenn wir den
jetzt schon eigentlich hinter uns haben
muss dass ihre Premiere Sorge den Wald
geht der klimawandelt auch wunderbare
positive Effekte die Grönländer ich war
neulich da freuen sich weil die
gletscherschmelzen sie wieder Tomaten
anbauen können sie Angst vor einem
Blackout oder besuchen sie schon so ein
Training weder das eine noch das andere
nicht ehrlich bin also ich glaube
tatsächlich dass die Situation für
manche Menschen diesen Mann wirklich
gefährlich oder im brisant sein wird ich
glaube aber auch wenn ich höre dass die
Gasspeicher jetzt zu 85% ja demnächst
auch schon gefüllt sein werden wenn das
denn stimmt dass das offensichtlich viel
schneller vonstatten gegangen ist dass
wir vielleicht vom allerschlimmsten
verschont sein werden dass die Preise
betrifft ist eine andere Geschichte aber
dass wir einen richtigen Blackout
erleben werden da bin ich optimistisch
dass es nicht passieren wird Herr Broder
blickt nicht so optimistisch in die
Zukunft wobei ihr das Thema von ihnen
ist ja schon eher Schwarzmalerei heute
Abend oder Herr Bruder nein das ist
puderrealismus
ist nein mir geht es einfach um ein paar
ganz simple Tatsachen die ich nicht
erfunden oder gefunden habe das Schöne
an der Situation der wir leben ist alles
wird öffentlich und wenig wird
wahrgenommen also die Fakten liegen auf
dem Tisch man muss sich nicht mal tief
beugen um sie aufzuheben und maßgeblich
für die Situation die wir jetzt haben
ist der Euro und die Europäische
Zentralbank die uns seit Jahren erzählt
es gibt ein Ziel eine Zielvorgabe
nämlich eine 2% Inflation die Preise
dürfen nicht drüber steigen aber nicht
drunter liegen und ich habe mal Zitate
gesammelt von einer Direktorin der
Europäischen Zentralbank von der
deutschen sozusagen von unserer
Vertretung im Olymp des europäischen
Geschäfts Isabel Schnabel die noch vor
einem Jahr gesagt hat ja man rechnet
damit das im kommenden Jahr die
Inflation sich wieder rückentwickeln
wird das ist so als würde ein
Wetterexperte sagen ja ne Lawine du
schon unten ist kann man wieder dazu
bewegen wieder nach oben zu rollen oder
man kann sie auf halber Strecke
aufhalten und diese Wirtschafts- und
Finanzpolitik der Europäischen
Zentralbank in Verbindung mit den
Brüchen aller Abkommen alle europäischen
Abkommen auch das Maastricht Vertrages
hat dazu geführt dass wir jetzt vor
dieser sandkasse stehen ich habe vorhin
das schon glaube ich angedeutet wenn die
Europäische Zentralbank Milliarden Euro
in den Markt pumpt dann wird nicht mal
ein
volkswirtschaftsstudent im ersten
Semester damit rechnen dass das keine
Inflation gibt natürlich gibt das
Inflation das ist ein Naturgesetz dafür
muss man nicht kennes oder oder ein oder
Milton Friedman studiert haben das ist
ebenso und das ist hier einfach völlig
aus der Sicht aus dem Blick verschwunden
und das zweite habe ich auch schon
angedeutet der Staat gilt als ein
Wirtschaftsteilnehmer ein teilnehmender
sagt man glaube ich heute ja er ist es
nicht er verteilt nur das Geld um der
Staat produziert kein Mehrwert da hat
kein Geld der nimmt Geld ein und gibt
Geld aus und hier hat sich eben die
Ansicht durchgesetzt dass der Stadt Geld
hat es gibt auch eine modern monetary
theory den nun wirklich
ganz nah bei David Koppe fühlt siedelt
Leute können Zaubernde dieser Theorie
vertreten dass der Stadt so viele
Schulden machen kann wie er will und das
aber genau die EZB hat keine Strategie
damit verfolgt also die letzten Jahre
und Jahrzehnte ich glaube die hat keine
Strategie verfolgt dazu sind die Leute
nicht intelligent genug die sind einfach
irgendeine Zielvorgabe hinterher gerannt
und glaubten es wird schon klappen ist
eine harte Behauptung ja eine weichere
habe ich gerade nicht zur Hand aber
lassen Sie mich nachdenken in Köln hat
man immer gesagt es ist noch immer Jod
gegangen das Motto das demnächst über
dem Eingang zur Europäischen Zentralbank
eingraviert wird
würden sie damit gehen dass das das
Motto der EZB ist es immer gut gegangen
nein das glaube ich nicht ich glaube da
steht natürlich dahinter dass die EZB
auch
EU-Politik macht und letztendlich sind
da ja sehr unterschiedliche Bedürfnisse
in der EU die die gedeckt werden wollen
ja man möchte natürlich nicht dass
diejenigen die jetzt viele Schulden
haben dass sie die Schulden nicht mehr
zurückzahlen können und die Frage ist
allerdings ob das die Aufgabe der EZB
ist ist es eben nicht eben aber sie
tut's ja ja man nennt das glaube ich die
Kraft des Faktischen oder so ähnlich ja
haben sie denn einen Lösungsvorschlag
oder wenn wir hier immer über die
Probleme reden was wäre die Lösung
die Aufgabe der EZB ist soweit ich das
verstanden habe als nicht Finanzexpertin
die Stabilität des Finanzmarktes zu
garantieren und nicht das Geld zu
verteilen nach anderen politischen
Erfordernissen und das könnte man
eigentlich von der EZB erwarten darf ich
kurz mit einem Satz unserer Isabel
Schnabel zitieren die Menschen und die
Unternehmen im Euroraum sollen sich
darauf verlassen können dass Geld stabil
ist dass also ihr Geld morgen ungefähr
genauso viel wert ist wie heute ja und
das ist ja wohl zwei Jahren gesagt ja
und jetzt würden Sie sagen da muss sie
sich jetzt für entschuldigen für den
Satz entschuldigen ich Entschuldige ich
kann mich entschuldigen auf den
fußtreter aber dafür muss man sie nicht
entschuldigen dafür haben die Japaner
ein anderes Verfahren erfunden welches
denn atakiri ja okay
Frau Seibert wie wenn sie jetzt blicke
als Bürgerin darauf fühlen sie sich
dennoch sicher was das Geld betrifft
nein überhaupt nicht also ich hoffe
einfach dass es gut geht aber ich glaube
man muss sich halt vorsehen also ich
würde mich jetzt nicht wundern wenn
wieder die Hamsterkäufe losging und
nicht nur was das Toilettenpapier angeht
sondern im großen Stil ich kenne auch
einige die das schon gemacht haben das
haben die so gekauft einfach Konserven
Lebensmittel für zwei drei Monate also
wie gesagt ich habe noch nichts in
Richtung unternommen als der Hamster
ich bin gesund aber es gibt Hamsterkäufe
die jetzt schon auch wieder erledigt
werden die sie auch kennen wo man sagt
ja und es ist viele haben sich
tatsächlich noch schnell einen
Kachelofen einbauen lassen oder so ne
was man sich dann ins Wohnzimmer stellt
Kamin haben Holz gekauft oder eben diese
Gas
Dinger also nicht was sie jetzt erzählt
haben mit mit in die Steckdose stecken
sondern wirklich was mit Flaschen
ja ich wie gesagt ich bin da noch nicht
eingestiegen aber ich glaube schon dass
es gibt bitte jetzt ist zu spät
vorgesorgt haben Sie auch schon
Hamsterkauf erledigt oder sagen Sie nee
mache ich nicht
also ich habe mir das damals
bemerkenswert wenn ich durch den
Supermarkt gelaufen bin und dann lief
ich an leeren Regalen vorbei letzte Mal
als ich lehre Regale gesehen hatte war
das wenn irgendwie früher im DDR
Fernsehen Supermärkte oder Kaufhallen
wie es ja geheißen hat gezeigt worden
sind und ansonsten konnte ich mich daran
nicht erinnern oder wenn ich auf Kuba
war da war das dann auch so also das
fand ich schon schräg ehrlicherweise
damals und weiß auch nicht ob das damals
wirklich so notwendig gewesen ist
und wenn ich aber auch ehrlich sein darf
jetzt fehlt mir irgendwie das
Verständnis oder wie soll ich sagen ich
kann zu wenig beurteilen ob das man
sinnvoll oder nicht sinnvoll ist und ich
habe es einfach für mich immer so
gehalten dass ich mich dann der Stimme
enthalte wenn ich es einfach nicht
beurteilen kann aber macht die Inflation
ihnen denn Angst nein die macht mir
jetzt nicht so viel Angst aber ich sehe
natürlich in meinem Umfeld was passiert
ich sehe wie wie Kollegen und Kollegen
das mir sagen und das macht mich schon
betroffen
auch hier vielleicht habe ich eine
Minderheiten Meinung aber ich sehe die
Inflation galoppiert klar das sehe ich
schon und das ist auch schlimm wenn ich
aber sehe was momentan woanders noch
Inflation los ist wenn ich von 20 bis 30
Prozent Inflation höre
beispielsweise in Russland wobei
natürlich Russland ja ein sehr
spezieller Fall ist dann sage ich auch
es geht uns vergleichsweise noch
einigermaßen wenn ich sehe wie es
woanders abläuft über wie gesagt
unsere longturm kann ich das nicht
beurteilen das muss zugeben
jagen sie mich nicht darauf fest ob ich
optimistischer Pessimist bin ich halte
wirklich so wie ich sage wenn ich Dinge
nicht beurteilen kann dann rede ich
darüber nicht finde ich ein Optimist ist
jemand der noch nie überfallen wurde
und dann seine Geldbörse hergeben muss
gut vielleicht wurde er selber noch nie
überfallen wir kommen jetzt zum Thema
von Frau Schröder heute Abend was sie
besonders bewegt ja mich bewegt bewegen
verschiedene Krisen des Westens und
konkret habe ich ein Buch geschrieben
dieses da jetzt mache ich den Werbeblock
global gescheitert der Westen zwischen
Anmaßung und selbst hast und da versuche
ich eine Analyse warum auf der einen
Seite
permanent eingeknickt wird nehmen wir
das Beispiel Winnetou das ist jetzt
nicht im Buch aber darum geht es
letztendlich um cancel falsche wie kommt
es das Verlage das Kulturinstitution
einknicken dass sie die Kunstfreiheit
die Meinungsfreiheit die
Wissenschaftsfreiheit außer Kraft setzen
nur weil einige Aktivisten das fordern
was steht dahinter und
meine Antwort ist da gibt es einen
Schuldkomplex der dann so anfällig macht
und wie hängt das zusammen mit unserer
fatalen Politik gegenüber Russland und
der Ukraine mit dem Scheitel in
Afghanistan im scheitelten Mali und
letztendlich ist meine These die das
wurzelt alles in einer wahnsinnigen
Hybris des bestens in dem Gefühl wir
sind omnipotent wir haben ein
Gesellschaftssystem das jeder nur haben
möchte wenn wir da die geeigneten
Bedingungen schaffen Stichwort Handel
durch Verflechtung das haben wir die
ganze Zeit Russland gegenüber getrieben
und auf der anderen Seite sind wir aber
auch verantwortlich für alles was
schlecht läuft in der Welt das heißt für
Klimakatastrophe für Hungersnöte für
Kriege für Fluchtbewegung etc und das
wird jetzt diese Art der negativen
omnipotenzphantasie die wird jetzt
ausgenutzt für Aktivisten die sagen ja
der besten ist strukturell rassistisch
die weiße Haut ist mit dem Rassismus
sozusagen identifiziert und da kann man
gar nicht anders als Handeln es gibt
tatsächlich solche Akteure die sagen
selbst die Kinder von weißen werden
wieder Rassisten werden weil das
unehrbar ist und ja das die zwei Seiten
von Hybris die eine die einen permanent
in der Welt auftreten lässt als ja
Personifizierung der Demokratie und
dabei schaltet und auf der anderen Seite
eben dieses dieser Schuldkomplex der die
Demokratie im Innern ausfüllt
letztendlich Herr Bruder der Untertitel
heißt ja von dem Buch der Westen
zwischen Anmaßung und selbst hast hättet
ihr auch von ihnen stammen können nein
der ist besser ist besser als der
Untertitel plakativ
müssen Sie mir noch eine Minute geben
also ich würde da gerne was zu sagen
aber ich durfte ja dieses Prinzip
kontaktschuld jetzt im letzten halben
Jahr kennenlernen also ich hatte ja
meinen zdf-job dann nicht mehr und habe
im Februar hier erzählt was mir wieder
fahren ist und ich muss mir muss
wirklich sagen ich mache mir große
Sorgen um dieses Land und um die
Menschen die publizistisch tätig sind
die von dem meinungskorridor der da
vorgegeben ist abweichen und das ist das
Thema Kontakt schuld wenn ich mit einem
alternativmedien mache XY ein Interview
mache dann laden mich die Leitmedien
nicht mehr ein aber das ist ja nur die
Spitze des Eisbergs was ich schlimm
finde und das habe ich selber
recherchiert es gibt Allgemeinmediziner
die haben Masken Attest der ausgestellt
oder auch eine
impfunfähigkeitsbescheinigung die werden
zu Hause auf dem Weg ins Bad am frühen
Morgen von einem Sondereinsatzkommando
der Polizei überfallen wie ein
Schwerverbrecher wie Terroristen werden
sie auf den Boden gedrückt fixiert und
dann sagt Ihnen noch eine ins Gesicht
ich werde ihn schon wer werde hier schon
was finden in ihrer Wohnung was für ihn
anhängen können ja aus einem dr Paul
Brandenburg passiert der ist
Allgemeinmediziner und Publizist das
kann nicht sein dass wir das in diesem
Land haben und das ist da hat die
kontaktschuld mit zu tun was ist weil er
gesagt hat dass wir hier in einem
faschistischen Staat leben wenn wir eine
Meinungsfreiheit haben davon gehen weite
Teile der Bevölkerung immer noch aus
dank unter anderem ZDF und anderen
Leitmedien das Denken die ja immer noch
dann darf sowas nicht passieren oder
Rolf Krohn Allgemeinmediziner aus
Kaufering ein Arzt der Kindern die
Asthma haben einen
maskenbefreiungsartest ausgestellt hat
der hat mir kürzlich persönlich erzählt
dass es mehrere hundert Ärzte in
Deutschland gibt die das aus der
Verantwortung der ärztlichen
Verantwortung herausgetan haben weil das
Kind nicht mit Maske im Unterricht
sitzen kann was passiert dem wurden die
Konten geschlossen die Immobilien
abgenommen mehrere Hausdurchsuchungen zu
Hause und das von der Exekutive dieses
Staates das kann nicht wahr sein und
entschuldigung wenn ich ein bisschen
abschweife aber es hat für mich damit zu
tun das ist für mich das Ende einer
freien Gesellschaft und es findet in
Deutschland statt seit circa zwei Jahren
das kann einfach nur selber für die
Zuschauer die damals den Auftritt nicht
hier erlebt haben sie haben ja damals
kann man schon sagen auch darüber
ausgepackt was sie im
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk erlebt
haben und wo sie auch die
Schwierigkeiten sehen in der
Meinungsäußerung was ist Ihnen denn
seitdem widerfahren na also es hat eine
Woche gedauert dann war mein
Wikipedia-Artikel gelöscht den hat meine
Chefin anno dazu mal 2008 angelegt als
ich das Berlinale Journal moderiert habe
also als ich quasi zum ersten Mal live
als Moderatorin für 3sat vor die Kamera
trat das ist das erste was passiert ist
kann man sich fragen okay gab es eine
Löschdiskussion aber Wikipedia-Artikel
Weg so erst ist dann bekam ich einen
Verriss von einem Redakteur der FAZ auf
meine Person der mit mir nie gesprochen
hat darf er aber nee
erstaunt und dann kam ein Herr von über
Medien ich meine das dürfen die alles
sind ja Journalisten auch Sie schon eine
freie Meinung haben aber für einen guten
Journalisten finde ich gehört es sich
dass er denjenigen oder diejenige anruft
also mich zum Beispiel ist ja ein Medium
was damit Geld verdient eigentlich immer
über Kollegen zu schreiben meistens
negativ naja daher nickelmeier ist in
mein guter Freund von meiner ehemaligen
hauptredaktionsleiterin und auch wenn in
seinem Artikel steht das ZDF sagt dazu
nichts war an seinen Äußerungen am
Telefon relativ schnell klar also von
diesem Herrn der das geschrieben hat
dass da natürlich nee das war René
Martens das er natürlich mit
irgendjemandem im ZDF gesprochen haben
muss aber im Artikel steht dann drin ZDF
sagt nichts ist ja dann auch die
offizielle Linie aber ne das sind jetzt
nur so die ersten Speerspitzen ich
glaube dass wir hier einen Geheimdienst
haben der sich um solche Kandidaten
kümmern die gegen großes Systeme die
staatserhalten sind was tun wenn man
dann aber sozusagen das öffentlich macht
dann ist natürlich schnell
wahrscheinlich dass die Frau spinnt was
ja schon auch der von den übermitteln
behauptet also ich kann nur sagen es
sind jetzt einfach so ein paar Punkte
das aber alles eigentlich wie harmlose
Reaktion im privaten Bereich weil das
ist ja meistens was was einem dann mehr
mitnimmt als wenn jetzt ein
Autor bei über Medien was schreibt das
ist ja dann meistens weniger schlimm
naja wenn man einen Job sucht und dann
läuft googlen die Leute wer hat sich
denn da beworben also wie gesagt ich
habe jetzt ich bin da völlig entspannt
eigentlich aber das sind die
Auswirkungen sie haben ja gefragt
aber privat kleine reden
kann ich nur sagen dass also die die
mich kennen und schätzen alle gesagt
haben danke dass du das gemacht hast
weil das war einfach das was du erlebt
hast ja da kann dich jemand in die oder
die Ecke schieben vollkommen egal aber
das ist das was du erlebt hast und da
bist du wieder rechts noch ultra extrem
links sondern du hast deine Wahrheit
gesagt
und das hat mich eigentlich bestärkt und
ja was die ehemaligen Kollegen angeht da
kam einfach gar nichts bis auf ganz
wenige Einheit den Kontakt abgebrochen
aber ich glaube es gibt da so ein
kleines Schweigekartell
dass sie auch gar nicht mit ihnen
Kontakt treten sich ein bisschen weil
sie kennen ja die ganz große Geschichte
und man kann natürlich in einem so einem
Auftritt nicht alles erzählen vielleicht
fanden sie es unvollständig aber das
sind jetzt Spekulationen also ich glaube
das ist in der Natur der Sache dass wenn
man weiter da arbeitet ist ja auch
menschlich kann es auch verstehen dass
man dann erstmal sagt hier was soll ich
jetzt sagen wenn wir sprechen würden
dann müsste man ja sagen dass man
vielleicht gelästert hat oder so
also es gibt es gibt bestimmte Themen da
verdichtet sich das immer mehr darauf
hin dass es nur eine Meinung geben kann
und ich kann mich erinnern als die alles
dicht machen Kampagne war von den
Schauspielern die Kritik an den
corona-maßnahmen hatte da war sofort der
Verdacht im Raum das ist rechts und
damit war rechtsradikal gemeint und das
kann man deshalb jetzt nicht ernst
nehmen heike hat sofort gesagt okay ich
mache da jetzt nicht mehr mit es wurde
ja auch gefordert dass selbst Tatorts da
Jan Josef Liefers nicht mehr der Tat und
Kommissar
zum Beispiel auf Instagram gefordert
dass er jetzt bitte nicht mehr der
Tatort Kommissar ist ja und und das gibt
andere Themen auch da es gibt wer sich
der offiziellen Migrationspolitik
kritisch äußert gegenüber ist sofort
recht sofort kriegt den afd-kultur
Willkommenskultur wer den Begriff
Islamismus wie ich das tue verwendet und
sagt Teile des Islam sind sie haben doch
auch in ihrer Uni Probleme erlebt ja
absolut ich habe 2019 eine Konferenz
gemacht mit dem Titel das islamische
Kopftuch Symbol der würde oder der
Unterdrückung da habe ich dann sehr
unterschiedliche Leute eingeladen zwei
davon auf dem Podium mit Kopftuch meine
Assistentin mit Kopftuch hat mit
moderiert aber es gab im vor im Vorfeld
schon eine
Internetaktion so ein Shitstorm da wurde
verlangt ich solle aus der Universität
geschmissen werden also mein Job
verlieren das ist nicht passiert weil
sowohl die Unileitung hinter mir stand
als auch Raster das ist aber eine
glückliche Konstellation würde ich sagen
ein anderen Uni sieht das nämlich völlig
anders aus aber dennoch hängt das immer
hinterher also mir begegnet das ganz
häufig dass
ich irgendwo eingeladen werde und dann
gibt es eine Gruppe und sagt also diese
Rassistin wollen wir hier nicht hören ja
warum rassistisch ja damals diese
Konferenz hat doch bewiesen sie ist eine
anti-muslimische Rassistin und das ist
jetzt ein Referenzpunkt dafür und und so
geht das also dass das Thema ist eines
das nicht behandelt werden er kann jetzt
kommen der Rassismus ja eine absolut
entgrenzte Definition von Rassismus was
alles rassismus ist wenn jemand gefragt
wird woher man kommt ist das ganz
furchtbarer Rassismus der verletzt
andere zutiefst und das darf nie wieder
gesagt werden Asche auf unsere Heimat
noch die Runde weil Herr Bruder bei
Ihnen das habe ich nicht ganz verstanden
warum wollte Herr Merz jetzt nicht auf
eine Veranstaltung weil er angeblich
nicht wusste dass da auch er Bruder ist
ihr Streitpunkt mit Herr März ich habe
gar keinen im Gegenteil ich habe ihn bis
jetzt verehrt jetzt ist die Liebe
erloschen und dafür ist im März
zuständig er wusste nicht dass sie zum
Beispiel auch auf dieser Veranstaltung
simuliert sagte Anwalt Steinhöfel und
wir waren eigentlich die die
Anschlusspunkte ich weiß es nicht warum
hat uns offenbar zum rechten Rand
gerechnet ich meine mehr Mainstream als
ich und steinhöfen kann man gar nicht
sein und ich denke ich will das märz zu
gut erhalten er ist ja auch ein
vielbeschäftiger Mann und mehr Zeit sein
Pressesprecher auch ausgetauscht
natürlich weiß ich glaube der hat auf
seine Berater gehört und die Berater
sind zwei junge Spunde 31 Jahre alt und
für die ist eben alles was die nicht
sind ist Rassismus genau so einfach ist
es so einfach also ich möchte jetzt noch
eine kleine Chance geben entschuldigt
sich schick mir einen Baumkuchen vom
Kaffee Buchwald und dann ist alles
wieder gut ja gut aber ich habe
jetzt kurz nachgedacht welchen Titel ich
gewählt hätte es wäre natürlich ein
geklauter Titel ich glaube immer aber
nur die besten ich hätte das Buch
genannt der besten schafft sich ab und
ich hätte Thilo sarazzi 9 Vorwort
gebeten aber ich will noch einen sagen
darf ich eine halbe Minute wir haben in
der Bundesrepublik alles was Sie
beschrieben haben kenne ich auch nicht
aus eigener erleben obwohl ich auch
schon gecancelt wurde aber das ist jetzt
nicht die Frage ich kenne aus meiner
Umgebung die Geschichte in den Ärzten
habe ich genauso erlebt als ich meinen
Bamberg eine Geschichte recherchiert
dann ganz normale praktizierende Ärzte
sind ausgerockt worden hat in den
Computer wird mitgenommen Ihrer Dateien
und sie wurden wie Schwerstverbrecher
behandelt später wurde daraus nichts
aber wir haben ja einen Tatbestand den
es nicht gibt es gibt in der
Bundesrepublik ich weiß das absolut ein
Tatbestand der nicht existiert und er
heißt Verfassungsschutz relevante
Delegitimierung des Staates das gibt es
in keinem Strafgesetz wohin keine
Strafprozessordnung diesen Tatbestand
haben zwei Koryphäen das Rechtsstaates
erfunden und eingeführt unsere
Innenministerin der Herr sei mit dir auf
allen ihren Wegen Frau Feser und
heidewand glaube ich der Chef des
Verfassungsschutzes
Verfassungsschutz relevante delegnierung
des Staates das ist sozusagen
niederschwellige Kriminalität dem
Strafgesetzbuch nicht erfasst ist aber
jetzt erfasst werden muss bei dem
stadtrod Gefahr jeder Mensch hat das
Recht den Stadt beschissen zu finden und
auch darauf hinzuarbeiten dass der Staat
ein anderer wird das macht die Linke
genauso wie die bürgerlichen Parteien
jeweils in deren sind aber ich kenne
keinen Fall aus einer intakten
Demokratie wo ein Sub subtat Bestand
erschaffen wird kreiert wird aus dem
Nichts geschöpft wird mit dem man dann
Leute kriminalisieren kann die nichts
verbrochen haben
wie ist denn ihre Meinung dazu zu der
Meinungsfreiheit auch im Journalismus
ist die gegeben wie sieht es aus mit der
Kennzahl schon in unserem Land
also ich kann nur für mich reden da habe
ich ja schon gesagt und ich bin jetzt
seit 37 Jahren in der ARD und ich konnte
immer frei berichten ich hatte nie ein
Problem damit mir hat niemand vorgegeben
was ich zu tun zu lassen habe nun
arbeite ich natürlich auch an einem
Bereich der sehr spezielles aber
unabhängig davon habe ich es auch in
anderen Kollegen schon nicht empfunden
also mir geht's gut vielleicht habe ich
Glück weiß ich nicht aber ich kann es so
nicht empfindlich sehr natürlich manche
Sachen tun Sorge in der Gesellschaft ich
sehe ich sehe erst heute hat sehr
wahrscheinlich auch laufen sein soll
nein aber da haben wir schon auf vor der
Sendung gesprochen dass ich mich dazu
nicht äußere in der Sendung zu solchen
Dingen man das war auch klar verabredet
und das mache ich auch nicht aber
trotzdem natürlich sehe ich
grundsätzlich
mit großer Sorge in der Gesellschaft wie
halt
links und rechts sich radikalisieren es
ist schon auffällig und
sie ist auch mit großer Sorge wie wie
wie intolerant man mitunter miteinander
und umgeht das erlebe ich auch natürlich
aber eben mehr mein privaten Bereich und
beobachte das auch mit Sorge für meinen
Beruf kann ich das nicht sagen also
eigentlich sein alle wieder miteinander
reden egal ob na gut
alle miteinander reden sollten also ich
finde die Art und Weise wie wir
miteinander kommunizieren finde ich halt
gelegentlich schlimm und mein Thema ist
wenn ich seit Jahren dass ich sehe dass
die sozialen Medien die sogenannten
sozialen Medien häufig sehr unsozial
sind und das etwas was früher am
Stammtisch diskutiert worden ist wird
heute halt in den sozialen Medien
diskutiert bekommt dadurch eine viel
größere Präsenz und manchmal würde ich
mir wünschen dass es lieber am
Stammtisch bleiben würde was er
gelegentlich gesagt wird weil ich nicht
glaube dass es was hier vor noch gesagt
haben was manche Dinge die dann auch
Angst natürlich ganz besonders eben auch
noch quasi multiplizieren wir ich habe
das Gefühl dass wir gelegentlich eben
auch als Medien uns überlegen sollten ob
wir der Angst hat so viel
vorschubleisten oder sondern versuchen
ab und zu mal ein bisschen mäßigen
einzuwirken aber das sind halt auch eine
Beobachtung mit dem Wunsch gehen wir
jetzt in eine ganz kurze Unterbrechung
und sind dann auch gleich wieder zurück
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter bauen und
ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei Viertel acht fünf Köpfen fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatjet Uschi Wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit wir sind
grünroten steht da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum
wuseln die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig um es nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz anders
also
das sind irgendwelche anorakträger aus
Buxtehude die das Gucken so ich habe
mein Beifall in meiner lache immer
bekommen wer kümmert sich darum niemand
dit ist ja man muss da ganz klar jetzt
mal auch darüber sprechen das ist
einfach nicht fair ist und nicht richtig
Aufgabe von Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
ja und keiner da geht aber keiner ran
warum wir machen geschwind weiter mit
dem ARD doping-experten hijo Seifert und
seinem Thema heute ich schätze es geht
um Doping ja es geht um Doping es geht
nicht nur um Doping es geht um die Frage
die mich sehr bewegt und das als langen
langen Jahren nämlich was passiert mit
Menschen vor allem mit jungen Menschen
im Sport die instrumentalisiert werden
durch durchtritte ob das nun doping ist
oder ob das auch sexueller Missbrauch
ist damit haben wir zur kurzen
beschäftigt
und das unter dem ja Aspekt der der
Gewinnmaximierung im Sport werden Kinder
und Jugendliche häufig benutzt das ist
mein Gefühl und der Sport der
Leistungssport der Hochleistungssport
wird aus meiner Sicht nicht unabhängig
kontrolliert und deswegen ist es eben
möglich einen Art für dahles
strukturwesen über Jahrzehnte zu
etablieren ohne dass es wirklich
Interesse gibt dem auch mal nachzugehen
und das zu kontrollieren und ich glaube
dass wenn wir so weitermachen kurzen
Sport der viele Menschen auf der Welt
begeistert in seinen Band sieht dann
werden wir irgendwann erleben dass
dieses System sich selbst abschafft
etwas zeigen
ich bin von meinem Trainer missbraucht
worden er hat eigentlich keinen
Zeitpunkt ausgelassen um nicht seinen
Wünschen und
Bedürfnissen freien Lauf zu lassen
es ging
anfangslos mit Anfassen dass er
ja
mich dann
immer mehr also systematisch
einmal im ersten mal anfangen einmal im
Monat oder also bis hin dann später dass
es dann täglich war
zu sexuellen Handlungen genötigt hat
wenn man das sieht bekommt man
ergänsehaut das ist ein Ausschnitt aus
ihrer Doku und das ist ja kein
Einzelfall das ist kein Einzelfall und
ich habe am Anfang des Jahres das ist
das erste Mal in all meinen Berufsjahren
ein Film gemacht der nicht mit Sport zu
tun hatte da ging es um die katholische
Kirche da ging es aber nicht im
Missbrauch da ging es um 100 Katholiken
und Katholiken in Deutschland die schwul
lesbisch Transgender sind und die halt
gesagt haben sie wollen in der
katholischen Kirche arbeiten aber man
hat ihnen Fußfesseln quasi angelegt oder
man hat ihm gesagt redet bitte bloß
nicht drüber und natürlich hatte das
alles ein bisschen mit dem
Missbrauchskandal im Hintergrund zu tun
das bearbeitet aber so ein bisschen mit
und damals ist mir schon klar geworden
wie schlimm das ist allein in der Kirche
und wenn man an den wirkies Skandal
denkt dann dann also jede Mutter muss ja
Angst kriegen ihr Kinder in die Kirche
zu schicken aber leider muss ich
inzwischen sagen dass es eben auch im
Sport Strukturen gibt die mit weggucken
zu tun haben die damit zu tun haben dass
wir ein System existiert das vor allem
immer im Ziel hat Sport und die Sportart
zu schützen und selten das Individuum
und weil das halt alles möglich ist in
so einer Art für mich ist fast wie eine
Art Schattenwirtschaft der Check guckt
man nicht so genau hin da geht es halt
darum dass der Bund das Geld gibt für
die Sportverbände damit die zur Olympia
fahren können das ist halt wichtig und
Athleten die halt nicht das bringen was
sie bringen sollten die werden in einem
Land wie Deutschland dann irgendwann
hinten fallen dann hinten runter ich
frage mich immer wir sind Deutschland
wir sind ein prosperierendes
landvergleichsweise haben wir es
wirklich nötig sich über Goldmedaillen
zu definieren oder ist das eigentlich
ich sag schon mal dieser
Schwanzvergleich ist es eigentlich
notwendig ich glaube nein
wenn wir uns weniger darüber definieren
würden dass es mehr das Augenmerk aufs
Individuum gelegt werden müssen
dass wir dass wir einfach erkennen
müssen dass es einfach in an einem an
einem Gemeinwesen in dem man Kultur
guten Sport ist für mich in Kulturgut
das ist ein Stück weit auch mal
Lebensthema
wenn man das schützen möchte muss kann
man es nicht sich selbst überlassen
sondern muss man dafür Sorge tragen und
das will der Bund ja angeblich und ich
glaube auch dass es jetzt ernster
angefasst wird das Thema als noch vor
ein paar Jahren auch durch den Film
vielleicht ein bisschen initiiert aber
ich finde das ein Gemeinwesen dass ja
auch durch den Steuerzahler finanziert
wird und nicht zu knapp übrigens das
muss ich auch gefallen lassen dass man
ihm die Karten geschaut und ich finde
das passiert einfach im Sport viel zu
wenig und da sind quasi
Parallelstrukturen da und das ist nicht
nur im deutschen Sports würde es auch
international so wenn man sieht dass wir
beispielsweise beim Thema Doping was ja
am Ende auch nichts anderes ist als eine
andere Art des Missbrauchs wenn man
nämlich jugendlich oder Kinder mit einer
Bolika voll stopft und dabei in Kauf
nimmt dass diese Kinder oder
Jugendlichen damit gesundheitlich
Schäden davontragen mitunter ist das
auch schon so weit gegangen dass sie
gestorben sind daran dann finde ich es
einfach unglaublich wenn man dann halt
immer sagt ja moment mal Leute sind ja
alles nur Einzelfälle und das ganze
nicht als Strukturproblem begreift und
deswegen glaube ich ist eben ich bin
halt quasi für die Berichterstattung
über die Schattenseiten des Sports
zuständig und mir ist es manchmal schon
Dorn im Auge wenn ich sehe dass wir
dieses Thema jedenfalls war es früher so
ausblenden und wenn man ganz ehrlich
sind das bezieht sich jetzt nicht auf
Deutschland das sehe ich weltweites
Phänomen muss man nüchtern konstatieren
dass Olympische Spiele oft über den
gesamten Erdball jahrzehntelang
übertragen worden sind und da war ein
großer Teil eine Übertragung von
Sportbetrug und es war nichts anderes
wir haben weggeguckt wenn sie
Dokumentation machen was ich mich frage
ist was macht das mit Ihnen persönlich
also ich habe gerade schon wirklich
Schwierigkeiten gehabt diesen kurzen
Ausschnitt zu schauen was macht das mit
einem persönlich wenn man diese
Dokumentation selber macht
ist gar nicht so einfach zu beantworten
weil ich bin Journalist und ich bin kein
Aktivist und ich
habe eine gesunde Distanz immer noch zu
dem aber natürlich macht es mich
betroffen und es gab auch schon
Situationen in meinem Leben auch bei
Dokus die ich selbst gemacht habe wo ich
wenn ich es mir selber angeschaut habe
dann angefangen habe selbst zu weinen
weil es mich so betroffen gemacht hat
aber in den Situationen der nicht dann
jemand Interview oder geben gegenüber
sitze dann muss ich schon sagen habe ich
so eine gewisse professionelle Distanz
wahrscheinlich wie so ein Arzt der halt
jemand operiert der muss ja auch ein
bisschen Abstand haben aber unterm
Strich ist es schon so dass mich das
natürlich bewegt also ist nicht so dass
ich ehrlich bin ja auch ein Mensch und
als Mensch mein Thema war immer ich
finde Ungerechtigkeit ganz furchtbar ich
finde es unerträglich wenn ich sehe dass
Menschen benachteiligt werden und das
hat ja am Ende auch was mit Fairness zu
tun im Sport nicht nur mit Gesundheit
auch mit Fairness und bin und deswegen
kann es mich schon sehr ärgern wenn ich
er feststelle und das habe ich über
Russland zum Beispiel gemerkt wir haben
Russland Geschichte ja vor ein paar
Jahren auf die Schiene gebracht
hat Jan Hempel der ist ja heute auch ein
gebrochener Mann so erscheint es wenn
man sich den viele gebrochene Menschen
im Sport ganz viele und die die sieht
man häufig nicht es sind so
beispielsweise Fälle wo Menschen die
jahrelang auf dem Weg zu in die
internationalen Spitze waren dann sind
sie plötzlich verletzt dann wird Ihnen
die Sportförderung gestrichen dann kommt
der Sponsor und sagt will ich aber nicht
ist ja auch finde ich immer super wenn
ein Sponsor sagt wir sind für
fairensport wir sind für sauber und
Sport und wenn man sich dann fragt wie
viel geben die eigentlich in die
nationale Anti doping-agentur wie wir
investieren die eigentlich in die
Dopingbekämpfung dann stellt man fest da
kommt gar nichts rüber und am Ende geht
es immer nur darum dass das große Logo
dass das Sponsors bei
Fernsehübertragungen großflächig im Bild
ist das ist worum es geht und auch auch
dem Spitzensport am deutschen
Schwimmverband oder wem auch immer geht
es vor allem darum
eine eine
zum Beispiel
logisch also wenn ich kann ja sagen wie
das läuft beim Doping wenn Sie wenn Sie
dopen und Erfolg haben und keiner
bekommt es mit dann profitierte Athlet
der kriegt richtig viel Asche ja der
verdient Geld der kriegt eine
Goldmedaille kriegt man so einen
Verträge der kriegt Werbeverträge der
kriegt
Leistungsprämien weiß ich was ja alles
bekommt der Manager profitiert davon mit
seiner Provision der Veranstalter eines
Sport-Events war da nämlich prominente
Athleten im Stadion hat kommen mehr
Zuschauer das Fernsehen überträgt und
dann können die ihre Werbezeiten besser
verkaufen haben hohe Einschaltquoten
alles super die Werbebanden wer will
denn darüber reden das Problem ist bei
Doping wie auch bei allen anderen
schmuddeltieren des Sports so lange
keiner drüber redet funktioniert das
System und aus der Win-Win-Situation
wird eine loose Situation in dem Moment
in dem plötzlich solche bösen Menschen
wie wir um die Ecke kommen und sagen ist
weil doch nicht so ganz oben na ja ich
finde ich finde das schon eine
herausragende Arbeit
ich möchte auch mal sagen übrigens auch
die Kollegen ZDF gehört auch mal dazu
aber Frau Schröder ist das ein Scheitern
auch ein globales Schaltern beim Spielen
und also was mir dazu einfällt weil auch
gerade der Vergleich mit der
katholischen Kirche gefallen ist das
sind geschlossene Systeme ja
geschlossene Systeme die nach ihren
eigenen Regeln funktionieren von außen
mischt sich da keine ein und die
existieren sozusagen als parallelsysteme
in der offenen Gesellschaft und und
ich glaube das geht einfach nicht also
es geht nicht dass wir zulassen dass es
solche Art von geschlossenen Systemen
gibt wo dann die rechte auch der
Sportler so himmelsschreien verletzt
werden also gerade der jungen Leute
natürlich die Missbrauch ausgesetzt sind
die vielleicht alles in ihrer Karriere
setzen und dann scheitern und nicht
wissen wie es weitergehen soll das kann
man eigentlich nicht machen das sollte
von Anfang an viel transparenter sein
diese Art der Geschlossenheit passt auch
nicht in eine Gesellschaft die sich auch
der Gerechtigkeit
verschrieben ja verschrieben hat und der
der Würde des Menschen steht bei uns im
Grundgesetz das ist doch Himmel schreibt
ja das hat doch mit würde jetzt
überhaupt nichts mehr zu tun Leute quasi
zu nötigen sich Token zu lassen ihrem
Körper zu schädigen und dann noch den
dem Trainer auszuliefern Missstände
darüber wollen Journalisten sprechen und
auch aufklären und Frau Seibert halt
heute auch ein Missstand mitgebracht ja
also auch ein Strukturproblem ich finde
es ist Zeit dass wir ein Augenmerk
darauf richten wie es um die gleiche
Bezahlung steht für Frauen innerhalb des
ZDFs und das betrifft sich vor allem
betrifft vor allem die freien
MitarbeiterInnen nämlich hat die
ehemalige Frontal 21 Reporterin Birte
Meier gerichtlich bewiesen dass es im
ZDF immer noch ein Fremdwort ist Frauen
frei Mitarbeiterinnen gleich zu bezahlen
wie Männer sie ist also sieben Jahre
lang durch die Gerichte gegangen die
arbeitsgerechte bis zum
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist am Ende
abgeschmettert mit dem Wunsch und das
hat das ZDF ihr jahrelang verweigert
Auskunft zu geben darüber was sie privat
und recherchiert hatte dass sie nämlich
weniger verdient als ihre männlichen
Kollegen und um das Ganze ein bisschen
zu erläutern es gibt ein
entgelttransparenzgesetz seit 2017 das
besagt dass eine Frau innerhalb eines
Betriebes Nachfragen darf beim
Arbeitgeber was denn die männlichen
Kollegen vergleichbarer Tätigkeit
verdienen aber es braucht in diesem Team
mindestens sechs männliche Kollegen die
das gleiche machen was ja nicht im Team
der Fall ist also dieses Gesetz ist
schon mal verwässert und in sich schon
mal nicht ganz rund denn das ZDF hat
dann umgekehrt einfach gesagt nö ist
also in meinem Fall zum Beispiel habe
ich auch angefragt 2017 es gibt in ihrem
Team nicht sechs männliche Kollegen also
können wir diesen Vergleich nicht machen
und weil sie freie Mitarbeiterinnen sind
haben sie auch kein Recht darauf ja und
was sie aber geschafft hat würde Meyer
diese Frontal 21 Reporterin durch diese
sieben Jahre Gerichtsweg nicht dass die
gleich viel verdient aber sie hat
geschafft dass jetzt Mitarbeiterinnen
die frei sind auch ein Recht haben diese
Auskunft vom ZDF zu bekommen auf dieser
Ebene wird also im kleinen aber mit
langen Gerichts wegen die nervenkosten
die Biografien nachhaltig schädigen wird
Politik gemacht Personalpolitik und das
muss aufhören und deswegen fordere ich
erstens die Führung des ZDFs auf ihre
Strukturen was das angeht transparent zu
machen offenzulegen wie hier Frauen
bezahlt werden erstens und zweitens for
die Mitarbeiterinnen die Freien auf
nicht sich zu scheuen eine
Rechtsschutzversicherung abzuschließen
und dann den Weg durch die
arbeitsgerechte zu gehen damit sie
endlich gleich bezahlt werden wie Männer
im vergleichbarer Tätigkeit Frau Seibert
ihn ist damals ja auch noch zusätzlich
als allein schon der Mutter auch noch
das arbeitskontingent verkürzt worden ja
das war 2017 also ich habe 75%
arbeitskontingent gehabt und dann hat
man mir gesagt nein du bekommst jetzt
nur noch 55% knapp das hat zu großem
Aufruhr geführt auch innerhalb der
Redaktion es gab noch eine der ging es
ähnlich und dann hat unsere Redaktion
einen Brief einen Intendanten
geschrieben mit der Bitte dass man uns
beide vertraglich besser stellt weil es
kann ja nicht angehen ja das ist
rausgekommen wir haben eine schmale
lippige juristische Begründung von Dr
Thomas Bellot bekommen das Rest alles
rechtens sei das war das erste ich bin
natürlich dann selber auch aktiv
geworden bin zum Personalrat gegangen
und ich werde nie diese Szene vergessen
wie die Personalrätin vor mir saß und
ich sagte zu ihr wirklich verzweifelt
aber ich dachte das ZDF sei ein
familienfreundliches Unternehmen also
eigentlich eine Anstalt öffentlichen
Rechts und dann sagte sie ja Frau
Seibold aber nur für unsere
Festangestellten so und da muss man
jetzt wissen dass das Programm im ZDF
ohne feste freie überhaupt nicht
stattfinden würde das ist ein großer
Teil der Mitarbeiter die diese Arbeit
leisten und jetzt erzähle ich kurz was
einen Mitarbeiter definiert also ein
freier Mitarbeiter ist die Jura im ZDF
kein Mitarbeiter wurde mehrfach
mitgeteilt aber ich hatte von Anfang an
18 Jahre lang meine Lohnsteuerkarte da
ich hatte einen ich war im Dienstplan
ich war weisungsbefugt ich hatte einen
festen Schreibtisch eine E-Mail-Adresse
einfach nur schlecht und meinen Namen am
Türschild solange ich noch ein
Einzelberater das heißt es sind die
juristischen Kategorien dafür dass ich
eine Mitarbeiterin war so mit diesen
Kategorien bin ich natürlich da jetzt
auch rumgelaufen und es hat sich im Kern
nicht sind die beiden schlechter
gestellt ich würde hier gerne einmal
wenn Sie jetzt den Fall hören von Frau
Seibold und dann an den Fall von Frau
Schlesinger denken da muss man doch fast
schon plakativ sagen die da oben und
dann ja das Fuß voll könnte man ja fast
zu festen freien sagen ja so ist es und
die beiden Fälle hängen natürlich
zusammen weil dieser Schlendrian dieses
sich austoben im Luxus
an der Spitze ist nur möglich meine
bestimmten Verteilung der Mitte und es
wird von unten nach oben um verteilt
zugunsten von oben und nicht andersrum
und an der schlesinger-geschichte stellt
mich eigentlich nur eins dieses Geräte
vom Einzelfall und von der Ausnahme die
er zurückhaltslos untersucht wird ich
meine die haben da sechs sieben Jahre
den tollsten schlendern getrieben und es
ist niemand aufgefallen nicht den
stellvertretenden Intendanten dem
Justitia den Abteilungsleitern
hauptabteilungsleitern ich habe immer
ein Problem damit wenn bei einem
Missstand eine Person herausgestellt
wird wissen sie der Führer hat auch
nicht von allem gewusst nicht weil wenn
es gewusst hätte wäre eingeschritten
aber wir haben ja heute eine Sache wir
haben ja heute hier gesehen dass auch
ganz tolle Dokumentationen ganz wichtige
Dokumentation auch mit dem
Rundfunkbeitrag umgesetzt wäre das war
ja ein eindrucksvolles Beispiel für den
öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk wie
sollte denn der öffentlich-rechtliche
Rundfunk reformiert werden ich weiß es
nicht wissen Sie bei fragen ob er von 8
Milliarden Euro passe ich nicht und das
gehört in diesem Bereich aber sie haben
wir haben jetzt hier leider kein Telefon
Joker nein aber nicht ich würde ja auch
nicht in Anspruch nehmen als sei denn es
wäre Claudia Roth die weiß ja alles nein
es gibt hervorragende Beiträge den
öffentlich-rechtlichen aber allerdings
hat sich meine Aufmerksamkeit sehr
verengt ich schaue nur noch ARTE und
Dreisatz und da kommen wirklich
hervorragende Geschichten also offenbar
wenn die wollen geht das auch und
natürlich liefen auf der ARD wir liefen
in der ARD ja also auch mal wieder in
die ARD schauen für die Dokumentation
würde ich mir sogar die Sportschau
angucken
bei mir Sport völlig egal ist abgesehen
von Stabhochsprung das finde ich eine
fantastische Übung sie haben das ja
knapp 20 Jahre erlebt was wäre ihr Plan
für in öffentlich-rechtlichen Rundfunk
wieder reformiert werden kann also ich
würde gerne dann noch mal drauf eingehen
also ich halte diese Debatte was diese
Intendanten Gehälter angeht eigentlich
für eine sehr populistische
Scheindebatte weil es geht um die
Strukturen und deswegen bin ich auch
heute hier mit diesem Thema man muss die
Strukturen radikal offenlegen muss der
Öffentlichkeit gegenüber eigentlich eine
Art Offenbarungseid geleistet werden
zumindest was das ZDF angeht ich kann
immer nur vom ZDF sprechen wie hier
Mitarbeiter behandelt werden es gibt
Gerichtsverfahren das am Ende steht
immer eine saubere schweigeklausel die
natürlich nicht gebrochen werden darf
deswegen kommen diese Geschichten auch
nicht an die Öffentlichkeit ja also
warum ich ich habe ja hier eine
schweigeklausel gebrochen sonst die
meisten erzählen einfach nicht darüber
und ich glaube es muss aufhören das
Schweigen das sind wir wieder bei ihrem
Schulthema es sind eigentlich alte
Mechanismen der Kirche die hier greifen
es geht um Schuldgefühle es geht um
Angst und es geht um zum Schweigen
bringen und das geschieht meistens
entweder juristisch oder eben durch so
einen allgemeinen wie soll ich sagen
eine allgemeine Meinung die ja zu
vertreten ist und ich finde wir müssen
noch auf die letzten zwei Jahre
corona-berichterstattung zurückgucken
das haben sie ja gestern schon gemacht
in ihrer Sendung was die Medien angeht
ist ganz klar Aufarbeitung gefragt und
auch eigentlich eine öffentliche
Entscheidung das ist ein schöner Appell
zum Ende der Sendung wir sind schon am
Ende angelangt nächste Woche Dienstag
sind wir aber wieder für Sie da und wenn
wieder leidenschaftlich diskutieren
tschüss schönen Abend noch
[Musik]